The mob is very barely turned.
The best you can hope for with a mob is
to calm them down a little,
but they'll,
they'll rarely turn.
I think sometimes you have to walk and
certainly choose your battles.
You can't throw yourself against the
wall constantly and survive.
The way I think about integrity is to
remember that at the end of the day,
there's only one person I have to sleep
with and that's myself and am I going to
be able to at the end of the day,
feel that I acted with integrity.
I feel like I treated other people well,
that I upheld principles that I really
care about.
And that on some days can be really,
really hard because it's not,
it's not the evil people who challenge
your integrity.
It's the good people.
It's the people you like.
It's the people who mostly do the time,
do the right thing.
And what ends up happening is because we
have interests in our lives because
we're interested in,
for example,
not unreasonably making more money,
uh,
wanting a more comfortable life,
wanting to take care of our friends and
family.
Those are the kinds of things that lead
to corruption within systems,
lead to misuse of resources,
lead to people mistreating each other,
and it's not really very hard to call
out when somebody who is known to be
awful is doing something awful.
It's much harder when it's the good
people around them cooperating or being
complicit in that situation.
We said that,
for example,
with the me too movement,
right?
Where people are now exposing
individuals who have been known to be
creepy and awful people,
but all the people around them decided
not to stand up because it was too
costly to them personally or because
they have the attitude of it's not their
job to stand up.
So I think one of the things you have to
ask yourself as you think about whether
or not to call out bad behavior is can
you get other people to do it with you?
That will often help lighten the blow of
the backlash and then can you afford to
lose what it is you might lose.
And for some of us,
we can afford that.
So in my own life for example,
I've been able in many circumstances to
go ahead and call out bad behavior
because I have the resources to survive
the backlash,
but
I always try to think of at the end of
the day and at the end of my life when I
look back will I feel like I did the
right thing.
And that to me is really important.
I was raised in a conservative Roman
Catholic family.
And so the message to my from my parents
all the time,
especially for my dad was always,
you know,
if you do the right thing,
he go to heaven.
If you do the wrong thing,
you go to hell.
Well,
I never had faith.
It never worked for me.
So I became an atheist very cognitively.
By the time I was about probably 14 and
certainly by 16 and 18 I knew that I had
no belief in heaven and hell.
So then there was the question,
how do you make sure you do the right
thing?
And for me it was really clear because
my mother had said to me,
you know,
all the dog when the world you don't
really need,
at the end of the day what you need is
to know did you treat other people well?
Did you take care of injustice?
And for me that was a very clear
organizing principles.
So for me,
I'm not thinking about what happens
after I die.
I'm thinking about the end of the day
and the end of my life and thinking if I
look back,
will I feel good about what I did or
will I feel crummy about what I did?
And Catholicism irritates me for many
reasons,
but one of the reasons that irritates me
is because it has the confessional
booth.
And what?
What happens when you've done something
that lacks integrity is you go into the
confessional booth and you tell somebody
who had nothing to do with the situation
that you did it in.
That person forgives you.
That's I'm sorry.
Shitty system.
You can bleep it out if you have to.
That's a system in which you.
You're.
There isn't really accountability,
right?
Where somebody is able to just let you
off the hook and if you're going to live
with integrity,
you need to not have that ability to go
by the little ticket and get out of jail
free,
you know,
do your seven hail Marys and beyond your
way.
You need a situation where you have an
inner voice that says,
well,
you did that badly and you need to make
good on it,
and then you go and you apologize to the
person you hurt not to the priest and
you go and you promised not to do it
again,
not to God,
but to the person.
You did it too.
And then you have I think,
moral accountability on the earth,
which is where we live.
The moral experience.
We don't live it in the afterlife.
Every time I've ever called out bad
behavior,
I've been called bad every single time
when I called out the FDA on
inappropriate behavior,
when I challenged the office for human
research protections,
when I named Cornell and Mount Sinai
medical school is participating in
problematic human subjects research on
pregnant women.
When I at my local newspaper reveal that
city council made deals that they
shouldn't have made that were not in the
best interest of the taxpayers over and
over and over again.
I've been called bad.
Um,
you know,
there was one time in my life that there
was some kids that were acting
incredibly violently at the bus stop and
everybody turned to me and said,
alice has to fix this because alice
fixes everything.
And so because I'm the New Yorker in the
Midwest,
so I fix everything right.
And the person who is expected to be
obnoxious and cost stuff out because I'm
a New Yorker.
So that's what I do.
So I ended up trying to deal with this,
trying to call the school system,
which didn't help trying to deal with
the family,
which didn't help.
And ultimately one day just lost it and
drag one of these kids home and
presented them to the parents who were
not at the bus stop is they were
supposed to be in.
The father throttled me and I'm in front
of the kids,
which was rough for me because it's one
thing to be throttled.
It's another thing to scare a bunch of
kids and I had to do a lot of soul
searching about the question of whether
or not I should have bothered right,
particularly because everybody in the
neighborhood kept coming to my front
door wanting to tell me how bad they
felt about this,
but they wanted me to take care of them
because they were feeling bad about this
and I thought to myself,
well,
like at what point do we say it's my job
to fix all the bad stuff in the world,
but maybe if more of us thought it was
maybe if more of us had that New Yorker
voice in our heads rather than the
midwestern voice in our heads,
the New Yorker voice to me saying,
do get involved.
The midwestern boy says,
don't get involved.
Don't get involved.
If more of us had the attitude of,
well,
maybe it is our job to step up and stand
up to injustice,
then the pain of it would be distributed
better and we might get things done
faster.
The reality of standing up in terms of
integrity is people often back away and
say,
oh,
well you have the personality or you
have the resources and you have the
privilege so you can do this,
but I can't do it.
And the reality of whistle blowing and
and doing exposing of injustice is that
you're often alone.
Mm.